today on the matt walsh show aoc
tearfully describes the trauma she
suffered during the capitol hill riot
but how much sympathy should we have
and feel for a woman who encouraged and
applauded this kind of writing until it
arrived on her front door also five
headlines including chicago teacher
still bravely refusing to return to work
dr fauci reverses himself on masks
again and camilla harris's stepdaughter
is hailed as a style icon
in our daily cancellation we'll discuss
hbo's new documentary
celebrating open relationships we know
that's got to be good
all that and much more today on the matt
wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
so to a certain degree this is a flaw we
all share you know all of us will take a
thing more seriously care more about it
when we or someone close to us is
involved in it none of us are capable of
absolute altruism or perfect empathy
but if we have absolutely no concern for
the tragedies that befall others even
while demanding vocal and unending
sympathy whenever we are the one
suffering misfortune
then we've gone far beyond the universal
flaw of fallen humans everywhere in that
case
we're sociopaths we're even worse than
sociopaths if we outwardly applaud and
encourage
bad things when they happen to others
while still pulling the woe is me card
should we ever get a taste of our own
medicine
many of our politicians in dc quite
clearly fall into this
second category representative
alexandria caser cortez has
especially provided an illustration of
what happens
when when when that naturally imperfect
capacity for empathy gives way to
full-on sociopathy
aoc was talking to her fans on instagram
uh instagram
live last night and the fact that she
has fans to talk to on instagram is a
problem in and of itself but
she began describing in dramatic and
tearful terms
the trauma that she suffered during the
capitol hill riots
the description was replete with visual
demonstrations
plenty of uh cinematic dramatic pauses
and all the rest of it let's uh listen
to some of this
like i'm here and the bathroom door
starts going like this like the bathroom
drawers behind me
or rather in front of me and i'm like
this and the door hinges right here
and i just hear where is she where is
she
and um this was the moment
where i thought
everything was over
um
and the weird thing about moments like
these is that you lose
all sense of time um
in retrospect um maybe
it was four seconds maybe it was five
seconds maybe it was ten seconds
maybe it was one second i don't know it
felt like
my brain was able to have so many
thoughts
in that moment between these screams
and these yells of where is she where is
she
and so i go down and i just
i mean i thought i was going to die
and it gets even more dramatic from here
next she began to describe
what in who she was thinking about as
she confronted her own mortality it
turns out she was thinking about the
american people
and comforted by the knowledge that her
work would be continued by those who
come after
her let's listen to that and i had a lot
of thoughts
you have a lot of thoughts i think
when you're in a situation like that um
and like also one of those thoughts that
i had was you know i just happened to
you know be a spiritual person and be
raised in that context and i
really just felt like you know
if this is the plan for me um
then people will be able to take it from
here
um i had a lot of thoughts
but that was the thought that i had
about you all
um
i felt that um
if this was the journey that my life was
taking
that i felt that things were going to be
okay
um now she also said that she simply
cannot
move on from this trauma and anyone who
demands that we move on
is acting like an abuser she said that
she has been sexually assaulted before
in her life and she compared
uh those who who wish to move past the
capitol hill riots
to her own sexual abuser and if all that
wasn't enough for one instagram live
chat aoc also
also threw the capitol police under the
bus the very people who put themselves
on the line to protect her
she tells us about one of the police
officers who came to take her to safety
and she said that she was
scared of him because he was being mean
about it and he was yelling
yes he was yelling it's almost like you
know there was a mob of people this guy
was trying to deal with and he didn't
have time for pleasantries
seems understandable to me but aoc
thought and still thinks that it's quite
suspicious
and was happy to tell us about that the
media of course
ate all this up insisting that her
description of the riot was emotional
and compelling and demanding
uh and that it was demanding of our
attention and affirmation
and under normal circumstances i would
have little problem with anything that
she said aside from the part where she
smeared the men who
who were protecting her i have a problem
with that but the rest under normal
circumstances
i would say okay well that's how she
felt that's how she felt
but her description of the fear she felt
and so on
um you know it would provoke no protest
for me if not for the fact
that this same woman had spent the last
several months ignoring excusing and
romanticizing
the very same kind of chaos that she in
turn fell victim to
now i've played this before but let's
remind ourselves
so i think it could be helpful too let's
remind ourselves what aoc
said about blm rioting back in may
let's listen to that if you're trying to
call for the end of unrest
but you don't believe health care is a
human right if you're afraid to say
black lives matter if you don't
if you're too scared to call out police
brutality
then you aren't asking for an end of
unrest
you are asking for injustice to continue
and for your people to continue to
endure
the violence of poverty the violence of
a lack of housing access
the violence of police brutality and not
say a damn thing that's what you're
asking for
so if you're out here calling for the
end of unrest
then you better be calling for health
care as a human right
you better be calling for accountability
in our policing you better be supporting
community review boards
you better be supporting uh
you know the end of housing
discrimination you better be standing
up to for-profit real estate developers
that are intimidating people and trying
to evict them from their homes
that's what you better be calling for
because if you don't call for those
things
and you're asking for the end of unrest
all you're asking for
is the continuation of quiet oppression
okay
yeah if you want rioting then it means
that you just want oppression to
continue you want quiet oppression to
continue and
you have no right to call for the end of
unrest uh
uh uh unless you want unless you call
out real estate developers
the whole list of of demands you know
so but what she's doing here of course
is she's completely ignoring and erasing
the people in these communities actual
human beings
who are affected by this injured by
damage by
killed by the unrest as you call it
but for her it's all academic so
sure we could get around to caring about
that but first i've got a whole list of
issues we need to uh discuss
first note that she said all of that
only two days
after a police prince precinct was
invaded and burned to the ground
and on the same day that she recorded
that video she also shared an image on
her instagram
giving people advice on how to protest
safely
and this advice advice included things
like wear non-descript
solid colored solid solid colored
clothing
uh cover identifying tattoos
she exhorted protesters to put their
phone on airplane mode and not to bring
anything they don't want to be arrested
with the point of this advice quite
explicitly
was to help people commit crimes and to
engage in mob violence without getting
caught
or while at least limiting their legal
liability if they are caught
and this is the stance she had towards
riding all through the summer two
billion dollars in damage 25 people
killed
the only people she condemned throughout
all of that were those who wanted the
violence to end
those who wanted to be safe in their own
communities again
but the shoe ends up on the other foot
and she comes face to face with the kind
of anarchy that she fomented and
encouraged and she responds by crying
and pointing fingers and
demanding sympathy and understanding
from the whole world
what happened to her is the greatest
crime in history a staggering tragedy
because it happened to her as for the
violence death and destruction visited
upon average americans
the convenience store owners who saw
their businesses incinerated the retail
employees whose places of work were
ransacked
the neighbors who were too afraid to
leave their homes because of mayhem
outside
the cancer-stricken children huddling in
fear in their cancer centers
while blm riders smashed the windows
downstairs
the woman in rochester who was beaten by
two by fours
while trying to stop looters from
destroying her business the retired
police captain shot dead
left to bleed out in the street random
pedestrians harassed and assaulted and
so on
as for all of them aoc has no concern
doesn't care
never said a word about them ever still
has not never even acknowledged them
in fact she applauds their victimization
she sits back at a distance and
pontificates about uh
their suffering and declares that their
suffering is worth it because it's all
in service to a good cause
because we're sticking it to those real
estate developers
yeah i mean so they burn down apartment
complexes
that that'll really that'll really you
know that'll really show the real estate
developers no no
well the problem is that they're people
are going to live in those homes actual
regular people
aoc doesn't care about them she doesn't
give a damn about them
you know it's all for a good cause what
is that cause exactly
and how does how does this advance it
well she can't say precisely nobody ever
could
all she was sure of is that two billion
dollars of property damage and 25 people
dead
wasn't enough to earn condemnation
indeed anyone who condemned it
was racist and then one day she gets an
up close and personal look at what
rioting
is and what it feels like on the ground
and she sees that it's not just
unrest it's terrifying
she was fortunate enough to get that
look have that experience as a heavily
protected public figure with cops around
to whisk her to safety which they did
not not that she has any gratitude for
those people who protected her of course
but the fact remains that she had that
protection you know who didn't have that
protection how about the elderly man in
kenosha who went to stop the
blm riders from looting his mattress
store only to be attacked
bashed over the head and left lying on
the sidewalk with a broken jaw
he had no protection he had no defense
after the fact either from people like
aoc
she didn't give a damn about him or
anyone else any of the thousands of
others
victimized in similar ways over the
summer quite the contrary she
romanticized
the sort of violence that he fell victim
to
while her democrat pals helped to bail
out the rioters and put them back on the
street to do it all again the next day
she wants us now to forget all that and
focus on her
and her own alleged trauma that really
is the motto she lives by isn't it
forget all that and focus on me hey guys
i feel like we're not
talking about me enough here
but sorry aoc a lot of us are just not
going to play that game
we're not we have no doubt that what you
experienced was quite unpleasant
not as unpleasant as being beaten or
brutalized or shot dead
as so many americans were during the blm
riots but
unpleasant all the same maybe if you
admitted your role in normalizing and
encouraging this sort of violence and
apologized for it
and held yourself to account then we
could make some progress we could get
somewhere
but you won't do that you aren't capable
and so you just can't get the sympathy
you desire
let's get now to our five headlines
well i won't even count this as a
headline because it's not worthy of it
but i do have to mention
that today is february 2nd which means
it's groundhog day um and uh
that's when we pull the groundhog out of
course and we see if it uh
saw shadow i still don't know but i've
we got the footage here and for some
reason i'm gonna play this
we'll play some of it anyway uh they
pulled out punks
punxsutawney phil to see what's going on
are we going to have more winter or not
and let's let's play let's play the
footage let's find out what phil has to
say
come around
hi what do you think wait a minute let
me
see this one is it this one
okay okay oh
he's talking to the groundhog right now
by the way you look beautiful today
all right he's whispering sweet nothings
in the groundhogs here
we think we have a prediction shingle
shaker
can you read it i've never seen this
before i didn't know how this actually
worked
okay here's here's the prediction hear
ye
hear ye hear ye now this second day of
february
2021 the 135th
annual track of punxsutawney groundhog
club
punxsutawney phil the seer of sears the
president what's the prediction
of all prognosticators was awakened from
his birth can we get to the point
on this quiet morning where a few
kennedys yes
we get it in groundhog he's phil
directed the president
and the inner circle to his prediction
scroll that reads
it's a beautiful morning this i can see
okay i give up i've listened to enough
you know what we're not we're just not
gonna know
we're not gonna know if there's gonna be
more winter or not we never got the
prediction
i mean i get see i i understand you have
to drag it out
because you've made this tradition out
of talking to a groundhog
and so you got to figure out ways to add
pageantry to it but
just get to the point i have to i've
actually never watched that before i
think
my only um experience with groundhog day
like everybody else is the bill murray
movie
and uh but i've never actually watched
it live like that
i've never seen the real thing and it's
even dumber than i ever
expected it would be it's kind of
embarrassing to watch are we can we be
done with the whole groundhog day thing
i get it it's a
you know it's a quaint tradition i
understand
but is it look i'm not trying to be a
hater well i guess i am but
isn't it a little bit too stupid
it's a it's a little bit too stupid
right
um okay i did just look it up and it
turns out we're gonna have six more
weeks of winter
so just bad news all we ever get is bad
news anymore
now even the groundhog couldn't even do
us a favor by giving a spring early
all right um okay let's move on to real
news
a chicago teachers union member was on
cnn yesterday
to talk about what it would take to get
her back to work
and here's what she said your union says
that agreements were reached on some
serious issues like health and safety
protocols
ventilation contact tracing and safety
committees
what is outstanding what are your
concerns that remain
well my concerns that remain um the
number one concern i have is that kovit
is still spreading
in chicago many of the communities
in which we teach covet is well above
10 community spread
and i don't believe that we've reached
an agreement on the question of how are
vaccines going to be distributed to the
people who work
in the schools let alone people in those
hardest hit communities
we really have not reached agreement on
the question of accommodations
for people like myself i live within a
multi-generational household
with my public school student as well as
my elderly parents
my mother has very serious health
um concerns and disabilities
come so far and coveted we see the
vaccine it's like a light at the end of
the tunnel
and the idea of exposing her now to this
virus is terrifying so
a really big issue
sorry i was still just thinking about
the groundhog actually let's think about
groundhog state those these people
they put on a suit and top hat to go
talk to a groundhog
and the thing about it is that there's
no doesn't appear to be any
it's not like tongue-in-cheek they don't
they don't appear to be in on the joke
it's like they're really taking it
seriously it seems like
yeah i say it's when it's course uh
they've been doing groundhog's day for
like 100
over a century i think well over a
century this
of all the traditions all traditions are
getting torn down all around us
this is the one we keep doing talking to
the groundhog
i guess i should take the opposite
approach because we're getting rid of
all the other traditions
let's cling on to any that we still have
and groundhog day is one of them so
anyway uh yeah the teacher was just uh
speaking there i i did tune her out a
little bit because you know what i'm
tired of the
excuses and uh what what's she she was
asked
you know what's it gonna take to get
back in the schools and you notice she
didn't say
well i want to get back into school to
to you know be there for the kids and
educate the kids
this is never about the kids you notice
that with these teachers
that are refusing to go back to work
it's not about the kids the kids are
just just disregarded
it's not even that they're worried um
about the kids getting sick
it's not about the kids at all the kids
are are disregarded
are not a concern whatsoever it's all
about them and so say this me me me this
is how i feel this is what it's gonna
make me feel like
and so she says what's gonna take to get
her back in the school is if there's no
more community spread which is another
way of saying
she's never going back because
coronavirus is going to be here
it's going to be with us probably
forever to some degree or another
and if it ever completely goes away it
could be years down the line i mean
literally years
it's already been one year
so that's the the standard she said
here's the great thing though you got to
look at it from the from the other
way look at the kind of silver lining
that
the teachers at this point who are still
refusing to go back to work
are all of the worst teachers anyway
these are all the worst ones these are
all the ones
that you don't want teaching your kid
so fire all of them that lady fire her
take her job away
fire the rest of them if that means
you're firing thousands of teachers all
at once
fantastic these are all the terrible
ones
the good ones want to go back and you
know what you separate
here's how the main way you separate the
good teachers from the bad ones
okay um it
this is not the only thing but this is a
big part of it
the good teachers care about their
students
and they actually want to educate their
students and it matters to them
the bad ones don't care
and as i can tell you from experience
being in the bubba school system for 13
years as i was growing up
you can tell when you're in the
classroom with a teacher who doesn't
care about you
and doesn't care about the education and
doesn't care about anything
and it's just there because it's a
because you know she wants to to sit on
her butt at the desk
hand out busy work and make a paycheck
as you know as the students aren't
stupid they can tell the difference
this is a great opportunity really
because all of the sit on the button
hand out busy work type teachers
they're all they're all identifying
themselves so what we should be doing is
saying
awesome you're all fired thank god
literally nothing is lost
all right number two from vanity fair um
it says in the past actor and activist
evan rachel wood has spoken about the
alleged abuse she was subjected to by an
unnamed ex
in an instagram post early monday
morning she put a name to the
allegations
she wrote quote the name of my abuser is
brian warner also known to the world as
marilyn manson he started grooming me
when i was a teenager and horrifically
abused me for years i was brainwashed
and manipulated into submission
i'm done living in fear of retaliation
slander blackmail
uh i am here to expose this dangerous
man and call out the the many industries
that have enabled him
before he ruins any more lives i stand
with the many victims who will no longer
be silent
and uh apparently so this has started a
sort of a metoo
thing with marilyn manson other women
have come forward and said he
uh was abusive to them now you know
innocence will prove guilty and all that
kind of stuff so we can't
declare uh what what is actually true
and what isn't
um i will say that i i find his
accusations to be very credible
considering it's marilyn manson we're
talking about
it's nothing shocking here at all
i mean this is a guy like if you go back
apparently he's still making music which
uh
that's that's the only surprising thing
to find out he was dropped by his record
label the only surprising thing about
that is that he had a record label still
so he's still making music but at least
going back to the 90s all the 90 kids
90s kids no marilyn manson he used to
he would get arrested for committing
sexual assault
on stage and if my memory serves me
correctly
this happened more than once where he
would commit sexual assault
for everyone to see on stage and he
would get arrested for it then he would
just be back out doing it again so
um yeah no not a surprise there and it
although
it does make you wonder like why
so evan rachel wood apparently got got
mixed up on this when she was a teenager
um so you know there was grooming that
went on she was a kid
and so you cannot you understand that
right
a lot of other women are coming forward
i don't know um it's it's
you do wonder how a guy like this
managed to have any women interested in
him
at all um or why anyone would come
anywhere near this freak in the first
place
but that's uh one of the mysteries
um then again you know there are serial
killers in prison who you know end up
and
end up getting married so i suppose it's
not surprising after all
number three we played the clip for you
last week of dr fauci saying that it's
common sense
um to wear two masks to double mask
you said that's common sense let's play
that clip again again this is him he was
asked about
about wearing two masks he said you said
common sense but let's play it
so if you have a physical covering with
one layer you put another layer on it
just makes common sense
that it likely would be more effective
and that's the reason why you see people
either double masking or doing a version
of an n95
okay so he says uh common sense or two
mass there you go
a couple days later this is i don't know
three four days later
uh he the the subject of double masking
is broached again
and this is what he says this time there
are many people who feel
you know if you really want to have an
extra little uh
bit of protection maybe i should put two
masks on there's nothing wrong with that
but there's no data that indicates that
that is going to make a difference
okay okay so it's common sense to do it
but
there's no reason to think it'll make
any difference probably won't make any
difference
there's nothing wrong with it but it's
common sense to do it
i guess there's a way you could make all
of that
make sense together i mean i guess there
could be things that seem like common
sense even though there's no data
supporting
doing it i guess you could say that
um but that's that doesn't appear to be
his and here's here's the problem
that we get these these messages that
contradict
or seem to contradict and it's never
explained
he doesn't he doesn't say in that
interview oh you know i know i said this
before about uh
double masking let me clarify here's
what i meant to say let me give you the
whole deal
they just say one thing one day
something else three days later
and it's up to you to interpret and to
figure it out
a lot of people a long time ago threw
their hands up and said
forget this i just don't trust these
people they're telling me different
things they're contradicting themselves
i don't care what they say it's hard to
blame people for taking that attitude
when you consider this and you consider
the fact that we're a year into this and
we're still getting contradictory
information so you can't even use the
excuse anymore that
it's early on and they're confused and
they don't really know themselves
they're trying to they're trying to
feel their way through it um that excuse
i wasn't convinced by that excuse back
last march certainly not convinced by it
now
number four this is from the daily wire
says the news website of a christian
organization was suspended from its
twitter account last week for saying
that dr
rachel levine the assistant secretary
for health at the department of
um health and human services and the
former
health department secretary of
pennsylvania is a biological male so
they were suspended for
for saying that rachel levine is a
biological male the daily citizen which
is a
a part of focus on the family engaged in
hateful rhetoric
supposedly according to the social media
platform when they tweeted january 19th
this is what they tweeted on tuesday
president-elect joe biden announced that
he had chosen
dr rachel levine to serve as assistant
secretary for health at the department
of human
of hhs dr levine is a transgender woman
that is
a man who believes he is a woman twitter
suspended the account for that now they
did apparently
um after i don't know a couple days or
several hours they did reverse the
suspension
without explanation and put after a
little bit of a time
out in the corner they just they let the
account go back up again
never explained anything they never
explained how this is hateful rhetoric
and it's not what was said there there
was no value judgment
there was no insult um
nothing like that they correctly
observed that it's a biological male
who believes he's a woman that's what it
is
that's what that's what that's what it
is to be it's with the trans woman
that's what it means
now i realize that people on the left
they don't like
that definition but
once again the same problem we always go
back to they don't like that definition
but they've never given their own just
like they don't like the definition of
woman
but they never told us what they think
the definition should be
because they just want everything hazy
and and obscure
and and undefined
and the great thing about that is if a
word and a term if a concept is hazy
obscure and undefined
then they can use it however they want
and you can't criticize them because it
doesn't really mean anything anyway
now although twitter have reversed the
suspension this is you know this to me
is kind of
this would have become sort of the final
straw um and i
we are heading to this point we're not
quite there yet
i think twitter and the social media
companies they're experimenting
they're kind of treading lightly and
seeing what they can get away with
but this is when it's sort of game over
when you're at the point where you
cannot even
speak accurately about biological sex
without being
banned from the platforms as it stands
right now
most of the time you can so for twitter
the rule is
as far as i can tell and it's it's not
that they ever explain these things but
as far as i can tell
most of the time if you go out and say
for example this a trans woman is a man
who believes he's a woman
most of the time you'll be fine you
could talk about you know you can even
criticize the concept of transgenderism
what they won't let you do is say this
directly to
a trans person you do that you're gone
you quote unquote misgender a trans
person you're gone
but as far as speaking in general
abstract terms they'll let you do
that not for long eventually you won't
be able to do that anymore and when that
happens it's just game over there's
at that point it's there's this they've
made it so that you cannot engage
honestly
um on these social media platforms and
in order to be on the platform you have
to you have to buy
into and affirm a lie in order to even
be there
and that's when real decisions i think
have to be made by conservatives on
these platforms
not there yet but that's where we're
headed uh all right this is from yahoo
says a week after turning heads at the
inauguration in support of her
stepmother vice president camilla harris
um which her stepmother is vice
president camille harris of course
ella emhoff has landed a lucrative
modeling contract so this is the
21 year old stepdaughter of camilla
harris
the daughter of second gentleman douglas
emhoff
she signed on with uh with a modeling
agency
and we're told that she's the new
style icon she's a modeling sensation
i think we have a few we have some of
the pictures we have some of the
pictures of her
of her modeling of her uh
modeling stuff i don't know if we could
play these pictures um
i don't know i i look at the i look at
the images and okay there's one here we
go
so we got the armpit hair we've got like
the
looks like a knitted pink eyebrows
it's like blue and pink knitted sweater
kind of a weird perm thing going on with
the hair i don't know i don't know what
this what this is here
black and white striped hat with little
like dog ears
and a bright what is that orange or red
i'm color blind also that's the other
problem
i don't know once again i have the same
problem it's the same problem i had with
the slam poet yeah i'm not a poetry
expert
to me i hear that poetry and i think
that's not real poetry
i think anyone could do that and i look
at these pictures and i think
again not look at me i'm not a style
what do i know my whole style
is i wear gray blue and plaid if you
haven't noticed that's all i have
if you go into my into my closet i'm
like a cartoon character which is just
like the same outfit
there's a 50 of the same outfit um
so i'm not a style expert but i look at
some of those pictures and i think is
that
really because i could do that
it looks like you just were you know you
didn't have anything clean that day and
you're just rifling through
your dirty laundry and doing the smell
test and grabbing whatever
is not completely pungent
and throwing it on and now we're told
that's a style icon
well all right what do i know
that's style now if you want to be
stylish that's how you have to look
before we get to our daily cancellation
uh quick word from our friends at
lifelock you know when you're going
online the most important thing you have
to think about
before you do anything else is
protecting your data
you don't want to just go in there and
uh
guns are blazing as it were and not have
any plan not have anything to do
in case the scammers come after you
which they will they're gonna they're
gonna make
their attempt right they're gonna try
scammers are using news of the second
stimulus right now they're always on top
of the news very topical
to steal americans personal information
some common scams include
offers to get your payment faster fake
checks or unsolicited messages by
someone claiming to be from the irs
links within these emails or text
messages could be dangerous malware or
phishing scams
it's important to understand how cyber
crime and identity theft are affecting
our lives it's important to understand
uh the the methods they use to steal our
information
every day we put our information at risk
on the infra on the internet
in an instant a cyber criminal could
take what's yours your savings your
credit your reputation
that's why it's so good there's lifelock
lifelock detects a wide range of
identity threats
like for example if your social security
number is for sale
on the dark web if they detect your
information has been compromised they're
going to send you an email send you an
alert
and you also have access to a dedicated
restoration specialist
if you do become a victim so you get
you're protected on both ends of this
thing
now look no one can prevent all identity
theft or monitor all transactions at all
businesses but you can keep
what's yours uh with lifelock identity
theft protection join now and save up to
25
off your first year go to lifelock.com
walsh that's lifelock.com
walsh for 25 off and the daily wire
is uh taking back the culture with with
unique entertainment content and if you
haven't had a chance yet
become a daily wire member and remember
to use that promo code rhf to get 25
off this is a great opportunity both to
watch the movie and just to get all the
other perks that come with being a daily
wire member
but we're not going to be doing this
promo forever um so you've got a chance
right now use promo code rhf to get 25
off and uh on top of all those other
perks you do get access to this great
movie that everyone's talking about and
uh it's a movie that that also maybe not
i would say everyone loves maybe not
everyone because the critics don't love
it quite as much
but it's got that 93 audience rating
with over 2 000 reviews on rotten
tomatoes which
means that the people uh they do enjoy
it so again
become a daily wire member if you
haven't yet use promo code rhf to get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we're going to cancel open
relationships open relationships
polyamory whatever you want to call it
all of that is canceled
now the catalyst for this cancellation
is a new documentary soon to be released
on hbo max called
there is no i in threesome hopefully
someone in the film points out that
there's no i but there is a me
and that's sort of the point a review of
the film on the website uh the rap
describes it this way says after a few
years of dating his actress girlfriend
zoe new zealand-based filmmaker ali lux
decided to document the year leading up
to their marriage but they aren't
focused on invitations and flower
arrangements
there is no i in threesome tracks their
attempt to open their relationship to
others
the likably awkward ali feels that he
missed out sexually during his 20s
and he sees the next 12 months as his
last chance to explore before committing
to one person forever
zoe a beguiling extrovert is game is
game so they establish a monogamish
manifesto and set out to make the most
of our bodies
while they're still stretchy okay so the
plan is to prepare themselves for
marriage by
pouring themselves out to random
strangers i'm no
nostradamus but i can safely prophesy
that this probably will not end well and
based on what i've read
it doesn't and when i say based on what
i've read i don't mean what i've read
about this documentary i mean
about open relationships in general it
seems here's a shock
very often they fall apart due to
jealousy and resentment
who could have guessed it yes it turns
out that when you love someone
it can be quite difficult to watch them
become romantically involved with a
third party
and if it's not difficult then you
probably don't love them
and there's the rub puns sort of
intended
now i wish i could i could say that this
topic is limited to a weird hbo
documentary or to a small group of
of swingers and other assorted weirdos
but surveys tell us that monogamy is
increasingly unpopular among the younger
generations
you take these results with a certain
grain of salt but but almost all the
polls
on the subject show an unmistakable
trend so for example
yougov just last year had these had uh
did a poll on this and here are the
findings they said quote
a january poll of more than thirteen
hundred u.s adults find that it finds
that about one-third thirty-two percent
of u.s adults say that their ideal
relationship is non-monogamous to some
degree
millennials 43 are particularly likely
to
say that their ideal relationship is
non-monogamous although an equal
percentage 43
of this generation says that their ideal
relationship is completely monogamous
according to this poll the number of
americans who desire monogamous
relationships has dropped by five
percent
in the last five years that's pretty
steep decline in five years
and this is actually a very serious
problem monogamous relationships
form the foundation of the family and
the family is the foundation of human
civilization
you can't build anything of significance
without a proper foundation and so again
this is a real problem i know we like to
say that our consensual relationships
are of no concern to anyone and
can't harm anyone else this is my
business not yours i'm not hurting you
that's not true actually for one thing
if you have
children then your sexual relationship
with a person who is not your spouse
even if it's consensual even if your
spouse is dumb or deluded enough to
agree to it
will definitely harm your children who
are now being deprived of the stable
private home they need and deserve also
if lots of people in a society give up
on monogamy
and thus choose to stop reinforcing and
stop strengthening
that societal foundation that's so
essential that it's going to affect
everyone
i i have to live in this civilization
that you are helping to ruin by giving
up on the family
i would say the ruination of society has
a very real impact on me it does affect
me
just as it affects everybody else now
all of that said it's not hard to see
why our culture finds the concept of
open relationships so appealing
the reason for the appeal is that first
of all we and i'm going to use the term
we in a general sensor
we are perhaps the most self-centered
society to ever exist
we are self-centered both in practice
and theory we are self-centered
philosophically we have
we have elevated self-centeredness to
our highest ideal
we're conditioned to think of everything
and to judge everything in terms of how
it makes us
feel and this attitude is reinforced and
encouraged everywhere we go in pop songs
and advertisements
in school even in church often times and
this is how we then approach
relationships
the whole concept of an open
relationship becomes
immediately absurd when you approach
your relationship as an opportunity to
love and serve the other thomas aquinas
said that to love is to will the good of
the other
if that's your philosophy then obviously
you're not if you're gonna
you're not gonna be even tempted towards
open relationships
it's clear that you're not willing the
good of your spouse or your partner by
sleeping with somebody else
right but these days people tend to
think that love is about willing the
good of
myself and so it starts to make sense
the other reason why open relationships
hold a certain attraction to so many is
that
we are materialists in this culture so
we see our bodies
as just our bodies there's no deeper
significance
our only job is to ring out of our
physical frames all of the pleasure that
we can before we die
so relationships are all about me my
body is nothing but a physical vessel
empty of any deeper meaning or
significance and with all that in mind
sure i might as well go out and have sex
with everybody in the neighborhood you
know that's the attitude
but it doesn't work the open
relationship inevitably gives way to
envy
jealousy anger and all the other things
you expect
unless you know speaking of sociopaths
as we were earlier
if you're a sociopath well the only
people who can really manage to have a
successful open relationship
are those who have little capacity for
normal human emotions anyway
we used to recognize such people as sick
and get them treatment now we call them
polyamorous
and have they have their own pride flag
they can wave for everybody else though
the experiment fails why is that well
because open relationships are a
contradiction
there is a fundamental tension that you
can't escape the whole point of a human
romantic relationship is for it to be
closed
the closing of it the exclusivity the
intimacy
is the point and that's because the
relationship has two basic functions
for purposes one as i already covered is
is to ultimately serve as the context
through which
and in which families are formed the
other purpose of the relationship is to
experience love
commitment closeness with another human
being
in a unique and intimate way
and to experience this for its own sake
to love another person for their own
sake
the ability to do this and to have
relationships that are defined
this way is literally what separates us
from the animals
this is what makes your relationship
with your spouse
different from the relationship between
say a male rat and a female rat
they're just bodies to be used by each
other as a means to an
end as humans we strive for something
deeper something something more
something more meaningful
why do we strive for it because we can
because it's a depth and and beauty
available to us to experience
because it makes us better people
because it makes life more worthwhile
now the people these days who reject
monogamy
they want to free themselves from
meaning and beauty
by behaving more like rodents and they
think they'll find happiness there
but they they don't they won't at most
they find a fleeting good time
followed by heartbreak followed by
intense loneliness
especially as they get older and now
they're left alone
and their bodies aren't so stretchy
anymore and
they can't they don't have the same
opportunities for those fleeting good
times anymore
but by then unfortunately it's too late
it's too late to find as they as they
get older now and they're alone
and they start to see the value and
meaning in that in that close
intimate monogamous exclusive committed
relationship
for a lot of them they find it's too
late to form one
and so they die alone and there's no one
there to mourn them
if you want to avoid that fate then
don't take the advice of this hbo
documentary
especially because open relationships
are officially
canceled and that'll do it for us today
thanks for watching everybody thanks for
listening have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 21. white house
press secretary jenn
saki circles back on the questions that
she can't answer
conservatives get cancelled culture
wrong and the liberal establishment
wants us to eat bugs check it out on the
michael knowles show